I was educated partially in New York
City in public schools we moved from New
York to Long Island attending public
schools in Long Island place called
Brentwood very large public school
system there I are I've often said I
succeeded in spite of my education up
because of it I attribute a lot of my
own success in education to my parents
influence which is ironic because
neither my parents had a high school
degree but they put a lot of emphasis on
the importance of education parts of
learning and so all six of my siblings
all graduate from college very good
colleges so a lot of it was really their
influence and what they instilled in US
schools for me would never I would say
that intellectually stimulating a few
exceptions along the way but it's a lot
of what I learned I learned outside of
school as well
I'm a sociologist and the focus of my
work for the last twenty years or so
it's been trying to understand the way
the social context influences what goes
on within schools so how changes the
economy changes in communities
demographic changes or impact children's
lives the family their families and the
schools they attend and so a lot of my
work has been involved in trying to help
particular urban schools but even
suburban and rural schools that are
dealing with difficulties in educating
all the tomb they serve which typically
means children of color children who are
poor children who don't somehow meet the
norm making sure that they could
understand what it takes to educate
those kids and I think that that
interest comes right out of my own
experience and in recognizing how vital
and how important it is to provide all
kids with the solid education
well you know there are many factors
influencing a dropout rate well I like
to remind people of is dropping out as a
symptom of a larger problem and if you
don't get addressed the underlying
causes then you never can solve that
problem kids don't drop out in high
school they typically the signs that
they're becoming increasingly alienated
from school show up much earlier and the
problem is that schools don't intervene
early don't or effectively some kids
leave because of the pull of the streets
some kids leave because they need to
work to support their families some kids
leave because nobody at school cares
about them they haven't made any
connections with adults because they're
bored because they don't think what
they're learning is relevant or
meaningful so there are a lot of reasons
why kids end up leaving school what I
found and is that there are schools that
serve large numbers of poor
african-american Latino kids that where
they are graduating where they are
thriving and what we don't do is learn
from those schools and do more of what
they do and what works and what you find
in those schools and generally is strong
relationships between the adults and
students a real clear sense of mission
about why they're there
understanding of how to make the
curriculum relevant to the lives of
those students all the things that are
lacking typically you find present and
so it's not as though it's as hard as it
sometimes seems I think right now we
have policymakers who are kind of you
know banging their heads thinking what
will it take to reduce the dropout rate
and I keep saying we'll look at the
places where you have low dropout rates
and do more of that
well I think it in the the factors are
internal and external so for example
doing work in Newark right now in Newark
New Jersey and has high dropout rates
one of the big factors is that kids
start to realize them in high school
there are no jobs for them in Newark and
so the the why stay in school if you
this if education is not going to result
in a real change in their life either
access to college or access to a job the
motivation is stay in school diminishes
over time so there it's what's going on
outside of school but also then you have
parents and adults in the community who
also have that experience of having
education not work for them
not open doors so what starts to happen
is there's a sense within the community
that education is not the pathway to
success and that's born out of
experience is not a myth it's it's true
and so what you need to do is you need
to start to create a different reality
by creating some schools that do in fact
open doors and create pathways to
opportunity for kids
well money is certainly important you
know in this country we consistently
spend the most money on the most
affluent kids and the least money on the
poorest kids so I would say if money
didn't matter then why don't we just
reverse it for a while and see try it
out but nobody is interested in that at
least not in the affluent communities
but nonetheless it's not simply about
money there are schools in high poverty
areas that have resources and you see
resources wasted or used in effectively
so it's money is important but by itself
is not a solution
it's how the money's applied it's both
the efficient use of resources but also
the effective use I you know and and
that's where good leadership is
necessary accountability is necessary to
make sure people are doing what they're
supposed to do it's essential that you
evaluate to make sure that if you set up
a program to help kids that there's
evidence that actually helps kids so I
would say that money is always a factor
but it is never a solution by itself
well I say you have to focus on three
areas you have to focus on them
simultaneously first you have to focus
on the culture of the school the
attitudes values beliefs the norms the
relationships typically failing schools
have dysfunctional cultures a culture of
blame or culture we're not working not
teaching is accepted and if you can't
find ways to change that you can't
really move a school so you really need
to focus on creating a culture that's
that's focused on accountability on
achievement on learning our culture
that's focused on on creating stronger
relationships between adults and kids
with greater clarity around mission in
addition to focusing on culture you have
to address the the systems in place
systems for how you make sure that the
curriculum is in place for how you make
sure that interventions that draw on
best practices are being applied to kids
systems that allow you to use technology
effectively that allow you to diagnose
learning needs of kids effectively so
there are systems that also have been
put in place so that that the system is
that the school is not just dependent
upon the whims of individuals but it can
can function even if you have a change
in the teacher or principal this is that
the school still functions as a as an
organization that has a clarity around
its purpose and then the third key
ingredient is always leadership you have
to have people in leadership roles who
have vision who have the ability to
motivate inspire the people around them
who have the ability to share
responsibility to mobilize and recruit
resources for that school you need
leadership to attract good teachers you
need leadership to sustain good teachers
because without a good principal in
place teachers tend to to suffer so
leadership is a critical variable and
all this leaders who know how to
generate a sense of buy-in from the
staff and then from students and the
parents are really what it takes to
create a highly effective schools
well I split no child behind doesn't
address it hasn't touched it you know I
mean here we have a lot that you know if
you look at the law itself it's
literally hundreds of pages long and no
mention at all over about the need to
create integrated schools think about
this by the year most demographers
project by the year 2040 or 41 we will
be a country where people of color make
up the majority to not prepare kids to
function in a world where they're going
to need to interact with diverse groups
of people I think is to deprive them and
deny them a good education there was a
time in this country where we thought
that was important where we were willing
to risk a high degree of polarization by
busing people and you know finding ways
to integrate communities in schools
we've retreated from that some of that
is because of the courts a lot of that
is because the lack of political will
where we are now as a country is
accepting the idea of segregated schools
and and I think it's like Plessy but the
idea of Plessy versus Ferguson was
separate but equal I think that's where
we are now we're still not an equal but
I think that many people are satisfied
with separate I think that that is a
huge political problem
I think there's it they will never be
equal because the the way we educate our
kids is directly related to the way we
value not only the children but also
their parents and the communities they
live in
and so I see this is a major political
challenge that there's not much
leadership to address right now
well I think we've had major setbacks in
the courts which have limited the
ability to integrate schools so you
can't cross district lines for example
to create more diverse schools so there
are there are legal limitations out
there but beyond that one of the major
reasons why schools are so segregated is
because in many cities this public
schools disproportionate serve the
poorest kids and what ends up happening
when that's the case is that middle
class people affluent people don't put
their kids in the public schools so you
end up with a two-tiered system a
private one for the white and the
affluent and a public one for the poor
that's New York City that's Chicago
that's most cities across the United
States the only way to address that is
to significantly invest in the public
schools so that the public schools can
really offer an education that the
middle class would choose for their
children so I think that's got it before
the strategy you can't attract white
middle-class parents unless you address
the quality of schools now it's also
true that there's still bias this
prejudice and there are a lot of white
parents who don't want their kids in
school with poor black and brown kids
and so I mean there are creative ways
you can address that through magnet
programs and other issues but ultimately
it does take change of beliefs and my
hope is that with time some of those
attitudes will change too
I think there's a there's a lot of
continuity from Bush to Obama in terms
of Education policy there have been many
major changes wait and I'm disappointed
about that I think that neither the
president nor the Secretary's clear what
was wrong with no chelev behind and what
I see coming from the administration so
far is too much emphasis on charter
schools and and and a tendency to frame
it as a competition between charters and
traditional public schools when you
consider the fact that the vast majority
of kids are in public schools I think
that's a big mistake I just think if you
don't have a strategy for addressing the
quality of education and we still
receive in public schools then you don't
really you can't really innovate and
improve those schools and so far I
haven't heard the administration come up
with any ideas that sound particularly
innovative they say they want encourage
innovation they never define what that
means or what it looks like or anything
else
well at the state and federal level
basically what we need are ways to
intervene more effectively in schools
that are floundering that the
chronically failing schools shutting
them down is not a strategy for
improving them it may be an option that
we have to consider but we first of all
need to figure out why were they failing
in the first place and get at the root
causes of failure and I think that I
don't know of any state governments much
less the federal government that has
figured out a strategy for doing that
effectively and so I would say that
would be one big thing they could do the
other big thing that's both the state
and federal government have to do is to
think about creative ways of linking
educational efforts to economic
development efforts if you could if
you'd want to improve schools in Detroit
you have to think what are the what jobs
are we preparing kids for in Detroit it
was not going to be manufacturing cars
then with any something else otherwise
you're gonna continue to have a mass
exodus of people from Detroit or
Cleveland or any of the other major
industrial areas in the Midwest and
Northeast so we need to think creatively
and strategically what are the jobs of
the future how do we make sure we're
preparing young people for the jobs of
the future and that's where state and
federal leadership I think could come in
much more than it has right now
unions need to make it very clear that
the interest of the teachers are aligned
with the interests of the children
whatever's good for the teachers better
also be good for the children and if
it's not then it's a problem it should
be the case that parents and children
are in total solidarity with their
teachers because they recognize that
when teachers work improves that they
also benefit right now in too many
places that's not the case that the
teachers union has defined its interest
in terms that are often antithetical
with the children's interest and that's
a huge problem it's a problem for the
unions because it means a lot of times
they're not getting this political
support they need and it's a problem for
the schools because - or from the
school's work for the adults and not for
the children
I think just the fact that it's so
difficult to remove ineffective teachers
is a real problem it should not be that
hard to get rid of people that we've
evaluated and that we know are not
effective it should not be that you have
a job for life just becoming to become a
teacher it's too important a job and
that not only when you when you when you
allow ineffective teachers to remain in
schools in classrooms and that only
hurts the children and it hurts other
teachers because the other teachers then
are it they're often have to to make up
for what that ineffective teacher is not
doing and so I think the union needs to
put if the unit really is ever going to
professionalize teaching it has to take
on much greater role of policing its own
members
that's what professions do they they
they evaluate each other and what's
interesting is there are a few districts
in the country where teachers now
evaluate each other and in those places
they actually remove a much higher
number of teachers than in districts
where is done by administrators
everybody I mean parents need to be very
clear about what their role is in
supporting their children they need to
understand that to the degree that
they're reinforcing the importance of
education that they are getting the kids
to bed on time to school on time
limiting TV and video games reading with
their kids all that will benefit their
children all the research shows that
when there's reinforcement at home for
what goes on in school children benefit
it doesn't mean that only
college-educated parents can do that as
I said earlier my parent neither my
parents had college degrees but they
really understood and reinforced imports
of education I think most parents want
to see that shown succeed but what they
need is help on how to help their
children succeed and many parents are a
loss about how to do that
well bonds in schools is to some degree
a reflection of violence in society
violence in communities it's very odd
that we would think we'd have safe
schools when we have such a violence
country that we live in with people up
guns and people being killed in some
communities quite regularly at the same
time violence in schools is often a
product of a dysfunctional culture kids
who are disconnected from learning
strained or weak relationship between
the adults and the students because
right here in New York City I could take
you to schools some schools are violent
to have metal detectors in sometimes
right next door
same school no no problem valence no
metal detectors what's the difference
the school that has the positive culture
where kids are connected to learning and
have clear goals tend to not have
problems with violence and discipline so
you can't address violence without
addressing the educational mission of a
school you have to make kids who who
think they're headed somewhere behave a
lot different than kids who think they
headed nowhere and and and that's about
the mission of a school and about the
ability of the educators to convey that
mission to kids in to instill a sense in
them that of hope and possibility I
think right now we have in the name of
safety turned schools increasing them to
be like prisons we have zero tolerance
policies we have police in schools metal
detectors surveillance cameras and those
devices and strategies don't produce
safety they produce an environment where
in fact we feel less safe because if it
takes a officer with a gun to keep the
school safe that we're really in trouble
what safety is a product of
relationships it's a product of children
being well known it's a product of or
byproduct of children being very clear
about why they're there and having a
stake in their own education the hardest
children's our discipline or kids who've
given up on learning and so what does
that tell you it means that we need to
figure out a way to make it matter again
and if you can't do that most of the
things we try to do in the name of
security will never work
most of the mass shootings have occurred
in places like Columbine Jonesboro
Arkansas and others were in
predominately white suburban communities
in most cases the assailants were white
males who were harassed or bullied by
other kids but what's happened in
response to these shootings two things
one is state legislatures have adopted
laws to lower the age at which we will
prosecute juveniles as adults so what
we've seen is an increase in the
criminalization of young people increase
the number of young people go into
prison for relatively minor crimes and
secondly this tendency towards turning
schools into prison like institutions
and that particularly happening in urban
areas and so I think this very punitive
approach is a real travesty and one that
neither makes school safe but nor does
it address the core underlying issues
first thing I would say is be careful of
your assumptions we live in a society
where our the conventional wisdom the
assumptions about why schools fail about
why students fail are usually informed
by stereotypes about race about poverty
assumptions that some kids or their
parents don't care don't value learning
if you believe that's the case then you
believe nothing could be done right and
agree that we believe nothing can be
done nothing will be done that's why I
always like to remind people there are
schools right now in this country where
you have poor kids of all different
backgrounds who are learning and
thriving and achieving and that is all
the proof we need to know the promise
not the kids the promise way we treat
the kids the problem is the conditions
we place kids under and what we need to
do is to figure out ways to make sure
that all kids have access to schools
where they are learning and where their
their needs are being met and that's
something that takes political will it
can't just be up to the educators to
make that happen we need communities say
we need good schools for all our kids